[Música]
hablamos de dos posturas del conflicto
entre Rusia y occidente según expertos
Moscú califica de histeria la
declaraciones de la Casa Blanca que
afirman que en cualquier momento puede
haber una investigación una invasión
rusa Moscú insiste en que no quiere una
guerra con Ucrania y exigido accidente
garantías de seguridad para evitar que
lado tan se expanda cerca de su
fronteras Esto es lo que más le preocupa
y le molesta a el kremlin un elemento
Pilar de ese conflicto ese el de la
estrategia de la que se traduce como
algo enmascarado y se relaciona con idea
de sorpresa negación y El engaño la
negación ha sido característica de este
enfoque de Moscú es el comienzo del
último conflicto frente a las
acusaciones de occidente de qué Rusia
Está tratando de invadir a Ucrania Putin
siempre ha negado que tenga esta
intención de hacerlo señalamientos o qué
Moscú califica como la histeria y
occidente de estas posturas que eran
varias preguntas realmente Moscú no
tiene intenciones de invadir o más bien
parte del nervio sismo de occidente pues
se le preguntamos a Nuño Rodríguez
experto en comunicación política también
inteligencia analista de Quijote globe
el portal tejido política y estrategia
Gracias Nuño por estar con nosotros en
ese espacio de Francia 24 llamado
directo América hablemos primero
Entonces esta táctica rusa conocida como
la más Kid of Kan que consiste podemos
decir que la está actualizando en la
está utilizando en este momento cómo
identificarlo
en este momento se están utilizando
estrategias de engaño por todos los
lados no es algo que sea propio de Rusia
evidentemente Rusia tiene amplia
experiencia dentro del campo de las
operaciones encubiertas dentro del campo
de la propaganda dentro del campo de la
desinformación y lo ha hecho durante la
unión soviética
y el bloque de Rusia y en este conflicto
hay más bloques no son solo dos estamos
hablando de Estados Unidos por un lado
estamos hablando de la Unión Europea por
otro lado estamos hablando de Francia
estamos hablando de Rusia y estamos
hablando de China qué es lo que está
sucediendo en estos momentos
occidental que simplemente acabe de
defender los intereses de occidente
Rusia ahora mismo no tiene interés en
entrar en Ucrania
llevado a cabo ejercicios militares en
la no cerca de la frontera
[Música]
de engaño de despiste en la que al final
simplemente van a estar jugando proxys
en el terreno y digamos entonces qué
quiere ganar Rusia con esta táctica del
engaño y también como usted lo dijo
occidente porque juegan a esta táctica
del engaño que está pasando realmente
pues
Rusia en este juego lo único que está
intentando es poder tener el derecho a
tener una relación de libre comercio y
de libre política con Europa que es algo
que Estados Unidos está intentando
evitar por todos los medios sabemos
perfectamente ahora mismo que hay un
proyecto
liberalizar las relaciones energéticas
[Música]
el principal objetivo en todo este
conflicto No no es Ucrania el principal
relación de libre comercio entre Rusia y
entre Alemania si Europa consiguen
encontrar una relación directa de
comercio
se podría llegar a formar una zona de
libre comercio desde la provincia China
de Taiwán hasta Lisboa Y eso es algo a
lo que en Estados Unidos
[Música]
el problema de la dominancia del dólar
un poco el micrófono porque está
haciendo como interferencia con el
movimiento de las manos para que para
que no haya interferencia en en su audio
por favor y vamos ahora entonces con el
otro enfoque del tema que le queremos
dar Rusia por su parte considera
entonces que todas las acusaciones de
occidente lideradas por Estados Unidos
son innecesarias y que forman parte de
una histeria colectiva realmente
colectivo o estas reacciones de
occidente tienen cabida y no son
exageradas en su opinión qué cree
yo en mi opinión y como analista llevo
viendo este tipo de acusaciones durante
pues 8 años ya desde que sucedió 2014
[Música]
de que hay un conflicto en la región que
consiga separar por fin las economías
europeas y la economía usa Claro pero le
quiero preguntar Entonces si toda esta
presión no se hubiera dado en este
momento sobre Rusia si cree que pudo
haber caído una invasión o eso no tiene
absolutamente nada que ver la presión
que está ejerciendo estos países sobre
Rusia
[Música]
no podría ser frente a una invasión o a
una elección de estos territorios
de Estados Unidos
[Música]